che bello limbo mi piace quando uno fa
cenno episodio di sta roba perché mi mi
mette ansia come se non avessi
abbastanza nella vita
buona visione ora basta però questa
acqua o basta basta che palle
quanto dura ok non hanno niente riempie
porca eva ma quanto dura sta roba
no non mi fa o non mi fate iniziare ad
ora mi incazzo è se mi fate riniziare
dall'inizio mi incazzo giuro mi fate
scendere il calendario sarà meglio che
si può fare è non va giù non va su
ma devo spingere ma che devo spingere
che hanno visto che si tirava stato
dai dai dell'elezione del giudizio di
dio e non si aggrappa però devo tornare
ho capito
ok minchia per che escludeva che l'aveva
visto esplodere veloce perfetto porca
vacca ragazzi tutto il tutto limbo
adesso sarà tutto così mi chiamo non
muoio per che tentò di saltare
scommettete cos'è il mister bean sta
roba mica pensavo fosse un check point
che se starò la a siamo proprio in un
edificio ma che bomba altra acqua perché
io devo risolvere gli enigmi con l'acqua
che problemi avete con l'acqua sarà il
ritiro
ok è no
ok
perfetto attenzione attenzione che ti
stai bagnando le caviglie quindi è
giusto che tu abbia risvolti ni
attenzione a non annegare è zio
attenzione che potrebbe essere grave non
vorrei mai che le tue caviglie
soffocassero no perché ci manca solo
quello guarda così si sta luce ma perché
pieno di luci ultimamente no no le larve
no ragazzo forse non mi prende
ma preso [ __ ] eva no no no no no
fermo fermo fermo dai zio alzi il
deficiente ma perché ti buttare giù qual
è il problema
come faccio ma perché non cambia
direzione scusami ma perché devo
camminare se non cambia direzione non lo
sapevo scusate ok
vai vai vai cori adesso corri
[Musica]
vai vai mai velocissimo e vabbè si
scassa tutto qua no no no no no no
che palle eppure l'acqua sale ci mancava
solo quello guarda
cambia testa di minchia non cambia
cambia direzione è ormai
lo faccio
non cambia e al frate cosa vuoi che
ormai suicidati si è mica se all'inizio
ritorniamo al primo video ragazzi cos'è
è ormai già ce l'ha fatta ce l'ho fatta
il culo do vado da nessuna parte che
sono morto prova bene
è comunque bello sperare a meno che è
ma serio michele pensavo di essere morto
tutta la vita invece devo andare così
che bomba rega salta veloce salta se tu
l'hai da vacca raga non so come
veramente credevo di essere molto tutta
la vita ma ce l'ho fatta non so come
questo sali che sta arrivando ad acqua
però è andata benissimo ma tu di culo
fortissimo il camino come un camino c'è
una casa c'era una casa
c'ero anch'io una volta qualcuno abita
nel limbo serio potrebbe essere la mia
vecchia insegnante di matematica e
sicuramente abita nel limbo anzi anche
all'inferno
dove salto ok tutto
beh no no no no no cazzo non ci credo
non ho parole non avere zio mi fai
veramente cagare a spruzzo dalla
disperazione qual è il tuo problema è
prima non andava bene scusami sai cosa
hai bevuto non lo so del latte ai ha
assunto del calcio nel mentre cosa
quando non ti alleni vivi in alto adige
come alex schwarzer cosa fai
non è vero non è quello che penso
ragazzi non è un hotel non può esserci
un hotel nel limbo che cazzo di gioco e
questo che c'è un posto del nel limbo
devo saltare sicuro qua sopra
cazzo è difficilissimo o più veloce di
così impossibile
e vabbè aspetta aspetta ma non mi sa che
devo tirare qualcosa di sotto no
porca eva ma quanto sta diventando
difficile sto gioco madonna sempre la
caga che non si spenga prima che arrivi
petto giu la corea
quanto costa una camera dell'hotel del
limbo quante anime a notte
vado giù su ma dove su decisamente su
qualcosa dice che devo andare suppongo
non lo so perché è però mi è venuta
voglia andare su quindi anche il cammino
di prima mi sa che era dell'hotel quante
grosso sto tel
insomma mica ormai ovunque vado meno
sempre un hinton ovunque
sarà mica un hilton anche al limbo tanto
sto vecchio sistema scassando ma non si
scassato e la scala che usano nella
biblioteca la biblioteca asshotel devo
fare a mi serve per darmi lo slancio ho
capito tuffo a bomba paris hilton melo
su ca hotel 5 stelle tutto e non
mettiamo i materassi per terra
cosa devo fare spiega mi era intuibile
sono io che sono scemo scusami una pompa
che non è quella della mamma degli
haters non ho capito un attimo questo
stiamo facendo
sto facendo il giardiniere il
bibliotecario dell'hotel così facendo
vado a sinistra non è che c'è di nuovo
l'acqua possono fare qua ma cambia mi ha
fatto fare i kilometri cambia
scommettere dove stiamo andando rega non
ho capito cos'è sta roba non è standa
aiuto
comunque la larva non sta più cambiando
direzione non so perché forse la cambia
una volta sola
beh no perché [ __ ] dovevo dovevo
essere più dentoni vai piano piano piano
piano fra te e allora si è un momento
per fare spiega ok e non lo sapevo e
scusate ok
lo capisco che è difficile 66 morto 800
volte qua magari una volta ci azzecchi
che ne dici piano
oh madonna che ansia guarda mamma mia
ok anni per passare ora ci ha messo bene
bello forse devo tornare indietro
ragazza non ne sono sicuro però non vedo
altre alternative quindi perfetto c'era
poi dietro niente non posso fare nulla
ma [ __ ] un'ora per tondo l'army o
porca vacca perfetto questo modo tira e
lo sapevo non so dove non capisco ok che
culo by zio vice io non ho capito dove
se mandandola sicuro devo fare così per
la sua anche questo caso si tira non ho
ben capito perché fra questi enigmi che
io non saprò risolvere perché mi fate
sti enigmi che non saprò mai risolvere
questo è successo
wow bene non ci arrivo perché sono pigro
e non alzo le braccia però che può
portare la cassa sicuro devo portare a
casa quindi giu
ok bene è stato più difficile del
previsto ma va bene è andata bene per
una volta
lasciatemi godere di questa cosa a
probabimente adesso devo ritirare sulla
leva e aggrapparmi prima che salga
questo perfect vai così verso l'infinito
e tua madre
devo andare a destra vero perfetto
tarzan e fiero di te frate fa chi è
perché ci sono sempre steccasse adesso
ho capito il perché ci sono sempre
steccasse ragazzi bene
mai sottovalutare l'importanza delle
casse in questo videogioco ho capito
cosa dovevo fare ma era troppo tardi
perfetto ai ok vinci spingi spingi
fratello
porca eva font ansia quanta ansia marco
quando consegnavano le verifiche quante
volte l'ho detto sta cosa ma chi se ne
frega fa sempre ridere
non è vero non faceva ridere neanche la
prima volta ma chi se ne frega quello
non fa ridere sicuro lo fa ridere senti
spider man
io non ci vado nel buio devo fare questo
dall'inizio prendiamo la scala
pericolante tra l'altro
andiamo non era un uomo ragno era una
una zanzara gigante una giga zanzara non
c'è l'autan e non lo danno nel limbo
scusa
devo scusa tratto non eri di sotto mi fa
veramente schifo mi fa piu schifo del
ragno giuro no non so come mai ragazza
mi fa veramente più schifo del ragno sta
cosa sono pacifico qualcosa mi dice che
non finirà mai bene questa cosa però ci
devo provare tesoro quindi ragazzuoli
spero che il video vi sia piaciuto
concluso quale episodio il limbo di tool
dei due episodi prima di arrivare alla
fine vi assicuro che ne vale la pena
giuro beh ragazzi